scott disick and bella thorne are at it
again 50 cent is crushing on Helen
Mirren and hard JLo is flaunting her abs
and shutting down haters and Ryan
Seacrest talks Kelly Clarkson jumping
ship to the voice plus it's new music
Friday and you know what that means
we can jam out hey friends this is the
daily Deni I'm Vinnie direct oh and
happy Friday to you today is jam-packed
so imma get right into it starting with
Scott Disick in Bella Thorne the two
reunited for a night on the town except
pay close attention because they are
holding hands as they left Lana Del
Rey's party and eyewitness tells us they
left in the same car arrived at a house
party in Beverly Hills around 2:00 a.m.
and left together at 4:00 a.m. now
you'll remember that just last month
Scott with snap making out with Bella
and kin at the time of source close to
Scott told et they were hooking up and
it was all just fun but Bella denied the
good times she tweeted that she's doing
legit nothing with Scott and she echoed
the denial when et chatted with her just
last week chilling my friends were coos
um I literally just saw him so yeah like
it's all chill it's all chill you guys
Bella also told us that she is and I'm
quoting her here single like a Pringle
so all the single ladies all the
pregnant ladies put your hands up and
just for fun comparison here here's who
Scott X Kourtney Kardashian has been
recently linked to that is 20-something
model
Yanis Benjamin I'm just going to leave
that right there for you you're welcome
now while Kourtney is getting her groove
back with a hot younger man 50 cent has
his eyes on an older marry woman and not
just any woman Dame Helen Mirren the
unlikely pair posed together at the
Monte Carlo TV festival on Tuesday and
clearly it left an impression on 50 he
later shared this Instagram of a
newspaper that called them out declaring
70 is the new 50 to which he responded
yeah I think I love her man I'm trying
not to stare at her she knows she turns
me on she just has that thing you know I
can't describe it I am living for this
and can you blame him Helen Mirren is
clean after all and speaking of Queen
take a look at this shot of JLo the 47
year old and fit mom of two posted this
selfie of her rock-hard ABS and haters
were quick to judge saying since a part
of her waist was missing it was a photo
fake out now jennifer has best step to
us before that she uses filters and
Photoshop I mean that's what they're
there for however not this time folks
JLo responded to the Photoshop claim
riding on G just a smudge on the mirror
lol not Photoshop hashtag gym rat you
should try it and wish there was
Photoshop for haters you better preach
Jenny now this isn't the first time
she's called out trolls listen to these
words of wisdom JLo shared with et about
double standards for women over 40 me it
comes down to stereotypes and putting
people in a box and I just I refuse to
be put in a box in that way do you not I
mean why because I'm over 40 so it can't
be sexy or is it because I'm alone moms
aren't allowed to be sexy how did I get
my kids in firstly don't come for her
people don't come for JLo judging by her
ABS she could take all of you alright
but moving on to JLo spell Ryan Seacrest
he's getting candid about the steal of
the century and I'm talking about Kelly
Clarkson choosing the voice over the
show that made her famous American Idol
take a look at what ryan told variety
about Kelly's choice I'm happy if she's
doing what she wants to do and she's
happy I mean that that first season was
pretty special so I've always been a fan
of her she would have been so good on
Idol then she thinks she could be great
on the voice as well that is very big of
you Ryan because truth be told when I
heard the voice stole Kelly and another
Idol alum Jennifer Hudson my first
thought was savage but the voice
executive producer Mark Burnett told us
it was not a deliberate ploy but he is
sorry truthfully meanwhile if sequence
takes the idol gig that offer hasn't
been made but reports say he could be
paid between 10 and 15 million a season
Ryan would have to fly red eyes between
LA's Idol on Sunday and New York for
live on Monday but he says is doable and
all I'm saying is like can I get a ride
alright before we sign off it is my
favorite day of the week is new music
Friday and I have some jammers for you
guys to kick start the weekend starting
with Drake we got a sneak peek of his
new single signs at louis vuitton
spring/summer 18 show ok
drake new song of the summer new song of
the summer i got to listen that whole
thing but giving him a run for his money
is time our favorite girls from the
valley are back with a new single little
of your love
[Music]
I freaking love it I can't I can't lie I
can't lie but I also got for you guys DJ
talent with another banger wait till you
get a listen to don't quit featuring
Calvin Harris Travis Scott and Jeremiah
[Music]
tell it always makes me make that stage
thanks so good imma dance my way into
the weekend but before I go thank you
guys so much for joining us all week
long we'll be back on Monday with a new
daily xeni
be sure to hit subscribe on e t--'s
youtube channel and head over at ET
online.com where we are covering all
these stories and a whole lot more have
a great weekend y'all tell it yes with
the bangles with the fingers